has omicron's bark been worse than its
bite well just a few weeks ago the
national picture looked bleak the map
got darker as the variant spread to
every region and the scale even had to
be extended because case rates were so
high turn that into a chart and
seven-day case rates race to record
levels in england scotland wales and
northern ireland
but then just as some fear that
christmas mixing would put rocket
boosters on those case rates they
started to plummet across the uk they're
now down more than a third from their
peak
some scientists have had doubts about
the accuracy of the daily case numbers
because the testing system was
overwhelmed but the hospital stats are
also encouraging this is the whole of
the uk
and there's a clear plateau and they're
likely to fall in the next couple of
weeks because of those lower case rates
it's all a lot better than the models
were predicting as recently as mid
december these were the most pessimistic
and optimistic scenarios for hospital
admissions in england in reality the
seven day average looks to have peaked
at just over 2 000 a day the blue line
right at the bottom end of the possible
outcomes so why has it worked out so
well well the first early models were
drawn up before we knew omicron wasn't
as big a threat as it looked on paper
with all those mutations
but plan b and behavior changes have
also had an effect adults are typically
seeing fewer than three people a day
outside their household before the
pandemic it was eleven
and mark wearing is now up at between
eighty and ninety percent
but the sudden decline in cases is
likely to be in large part down to
immunity almost two-thirds of the
population over the age of 12 has now
had a booster which gives good
protection against symptomatic disease
and is even better at stopping
hospitalization
and the eye watering infection rates are
helping too this is the number of people
with covid each week since the start of
december in just the first week of this
year it was 4.3 million now that all
adds up to formidable immunity that's
slowing the spread of even omicron so is
it all over well daily cases are still
well above the peak of last january and
there's still a chance of another surge
in the coming months as immunity wanes
but right now the numbers are heading in
the right direction